foreign
The Boys Are Back The Boys Are Back in
Town The Boys Are Back In Town what up
everybody welcome to the show y'all know
why we are here
y'all know exactly why we are here let
me introduce everybody my name is Greg
Aubry next to me is the man we like to
call MB or Michael Bowen he is the man
of the app
foreign
[Laughter]
so last week before yeah there we go
last week uh Logan our our Legend Who
cashed a parlay for us last week uh
coined this studio The Rat's Nest so
that there it is this is now I'm
embracing it right I fought the rat
nickname for too long now it's just it's
got to become a part of me so that's
where we're at that's that's that's
where we're at embrace it Ryan but
speaking of Logan last week bowling and
Logan came in here and cashed our TNT
Thursday parlay with ease
congratulations congratulations thank
you guys and I just want to let
everybody know that will not have been
possible if Ryan
joined the show and was involved in the
parlay that would not have been possible
if Ryan was involved in that parlay so
uh first of all didn't fall for my
tricks this time congratulations second
of all second of all I came in here and
I dropped bucks money line
that was maybe the juiciest play of the
night no it was not come on man minus
375. there are flaming Bulls Giannis got
hurt in the first minute of the game or
whatever and the Bulls still managed to
lose by a dub so it wasn't a
controversial pick you did give it but
it wasn't like people were starving for
Ryan's pick right yeah well you know you
know how the best bet goes uh if we
leave it up to Ryan if we leave it up to
Ryan the people are starving for his
picks and his Best Bets is like his best
bet is like 27-1
and that's not it it's ten in three it's
ten and three you know a man of humility
a man of the people and many humility so
[Laughter]
games in the chat Grizzly 76ers my
Warriors taking on those Lakers Ryan
what are the people talking about uh
well we got Zippy already jumping in
here with some nonsense saying Sixers
money line is a lock let's let's get
this straight okay this is the part of
the Year where the Sixers start to fall
off we're Philadelphia
returns to doing Philadelphia things I'm
not comfortable taking Sixers money line
I'll be honest with you I'm not
comfortable picking a side in this game
uh we have B Thompson who jumped in here
by the way 10 minutes before the show
started said we need to hit two in a row
that's the game plan he also dropped
hard at eight plus assists thoughts like
that like that like that don't don't
date Harden obviously he's he's a
distributor at all levels I I worry
Honestly though Ryan you were in Utah
are these guys gonna come back a little
groggy a little tired what do you think
here's the deal it's impossible uh to
party or drink in Utah they may be more
rested than they've ever been in their
entire lives so it's about what team had
more stars in in Utah I think they were
even I think it was just jaw and just
Joe L and B yeah um but I will say no no
no no no Justin Jackson was there he was
an All-Star
he's the former King by the way Ryan
foreign
[Laughter]
Utah I saw one Sacramento Kings fan I
thought they were lost I genuinely did I
I saw the walk by me with a haters
they had two All-Stars what are you
talking about one of them was a
replacement the other one was the last
pick in the draft like let's come on
let's let's let's be real this is this
is Sacramento all right I'm I'm jumping
in mal8384 is pushing rui hachimura over
three and a half rebounds hit in 10 of
his last 10 and we'll see more minutes
tonight only three
that's no that's a really good Scoop
because the Warriors are small
over three and a half rebounds maybe
that's where we started and that's in
the second game so we can we can table
it for now but Brothers we got some love
from the chat about the hardened play
we're just moving on man's at 11 and a
half minus eight plus should be like
that's free
yeah drop it in yeah let's go Ryan you
were talking about Sacramento you
brought up Sacramento don't put that on
me I'll put that on no but you kept
talking about it minus 850.
Jesus that's okay now let's go to rui
hachimura yes sir
minus 850 is awesome
it's unreal that's great the fact that
Ryan is in in cahoots what it is
mind-boggling
I'm trying to listen dude my ass is in
the jackpot I'm I'm on the hot seat
right Logan came and sat in this chair
last week and cashed a parlay I'm just
trying to get a win that's it oh so now
oh so this here to get a win okay
12 weeks wait gotta win now we get back
to the get rich scheme later and it will
be back we'll get rich I promise that
but we gotta put that gotta put that
plan aside for a second Greg you hear
him it sounds like he almost got fired
on his day off man or something
or sometimes
a man's talking another language MB he's
talking my language for real for real
but coming from him is just like I'm
mind-boggled I I don't know I this is
the new Ryan
uh yes dude do you go to Utah you know
what I mean you kind of just you're able
to flush things out all I'm doing is
looking at mountains and you know John
moranton and Ice Cube and I have things
to think about
um we there's bad news there's no Roy uh
Roy hachimura uh Hachi Mama as chuck
would say it uh prop here so oh no so
all right
uh unfortunately it is uh somebody
dropped hard in 10 plus assists we could
possibly uh uh revisit that when we get
more plays but
um I don't know what are you guys seeing
I'm trying saying the Anthony Melton
over one and a half threes against his
old four plus Ryan go to four plus
what's four plus hachimura
uh no
I don't know
uh sorry the guys the guys in the chat
said four plus
maybe he uh maybe everybody got on the
scoop and we're just a little late
or he's not playing
bagel and locks saying the Anthony
Melton Revenge game that's two D Anthony
Melton uh takes here in short order what
do we think I think we should go over to
the other game and check it out let's
see check it out
let's go check it out and for people who
don't know Bagel unlocks Logan our guy
helped obviously us get the parlayed of
the cashier last week but also I Avid
Philly guy so he does know what he's
talking about
I know that Ryan sometimes when it fits
his narrative is a Philly guy but that's
neither here nor there don't don't put
the Frog
let's let's relax okay if you know me
Philadelphia Sacramento Connecticut
that's a no-go those three are no-go's
for me okay don't don't say nothing says
the guy that had a it says they got out
of Philadelphia Eagles jersey on in less
than like a week two weeks ago did they
make me money Gregory did they make me
money I I don't think the Anthony Melton
let's go check the Anthony Milton what
do we uh what do we want
I think we I think we're trying to
Target some threes
one and a half over one and a half I
don't hate that
didn't you get some volume yeah one one
plus sounds easy to me
deloading yeah one plus sounds good yeah
let's see what it is
I'm seeing deloading deloading in here I
got I got deloading two threes I'm not
off to a good start
we're nine minutes into this show we are
we have two legs for minus 336. we're
gonna need a banger
yeah let's see let's see what else we
got
um
yeah deloading go to the other game Ryan
uh we we got it we're in a pickle here
we're talking assist I see g-smith says
six plus assist and I also see uh his
three pointers deloading two or three
three points made from ziby three two
six
yeah I like this I like to pick up with
him going back to LA I think obviously
they're gonna need some more time to get
all on the same page but the Lakers have
looked better and that's something that
I don't take any joy in saying I think
they're pretty bad but Russell's been
pretty damn good this year so I think
either way you slice it it's probably a
good play what do you think Ryan
um
here you go yeah yeah
what was it either a sister the five and
a half dimes that's not a lot for D
loading I was about to say I'm more on
the assist than I am the threes yeah
he's in the pick and roll a lot
and we're we're in plus money territory
they're ready to roll let's bring it on
Home Klay Thompson three-pointers
oh Jay Clark
140 says Klay Thompson three plus threes
that is not coming from me or my agenda
Ryan that is coming from the people you
should know better
Klay Thompson's band Austin Reeves this
band Dante divincenzo's band right that
was okay I they are they are banned they
I will I will meet in the middle on Clay
because clay just had a ton of rest
wasn't it in the Three-Point Contest
if we're time if we're trying to give
anyone on that list another chance I
will go with one of the greatest
three-point shooters ever it's Clay
let's just take a look Ryan like for
three years in your agenda but the
people the people are giving us these
plays I understand
huh four and a half's a lot three no we
don't need to go all the way up there
they said three plus three uh I don't
know man this is gonna be like minus
eight hundred we can't do that again
dude we can't do it again we might be
look at this
shout out to smoke grass420 he said pool
and clay and pool have sold me two
bleeping much which is really funny
because sometimes it'd be like that
I agree
I
I'll move I'll move on from my potential
Devil's Advocate on Klay Thompson if
it's minus 800 it ain't worth the play
uh l b a e said dear and fox over Dame
out but the TNT games the TNT games
Sacramento doesn't play on TNT they
don't they will they will in the
postseason no they won't because TNT has
the Eastern Conference so they're gonna
get they're gonna get Richard Jefferson
they're gonna they're gonna get somebody
else on the call
[Laughter]
is there a blocks and this is from the
this is from the chat so I don't want
people to be like Greg doesn't know what
he's talking but is there a blocks
section on uh oh on there on FanDuel uh
Greg doesn't know what he's talking
about
no player just kidding I don't I don't
think so no no no no
player defense player defense steal C
steals player blocks oh see Ryan C Greg
knows what he's talking about remember
that didn't come from the chat that came
straight from Greg's mouth there you go
Mo Bamba
okay now you got now I'm interested oh
humble
let's let's just look at the numbers
because he's gonna the winners are small
I see I see Mo Bamba threes or blocks
yeah
you have to press the you have to press
it Ryan so we can actually see it in
there not in there
A.D
I see ad2 blocks from Jay Clark 140.
82 blocks minus 125. I don't dislike it
I don't hate it you know the only thing
is like does he want to play tonight you
know who knows he's also very rested
listen make sure that the goal is to
make the sixth seed
they're gonna have to win 80 percent of
the games coming down the stretch so you
you've got to think that they're going
to turn it up from here on out I will I
will say this hold on uh darian85 my guy
our guy and B Thompson both really like
uh Jaren Jackson Jr blocks
I'll bet and he gets a ton of them I
think he had like seven against the
Bulls yeah I wonder if let's go take a
look because I wonder if his price is
super inflated
guys let's also take a look at John
Moran's points
yeah
for the Vengeance today you think so
yeah yeah I think so I I mean like both
sides need wins I think the Grizzlies
are probably trying to show that they're
still as legitimate as they think they
are in-house I think the Sixers are just
like right on that Fringe of
are we the best team in the East I would
probably say no but listen Joel embiid
lots of proof John Morant lots of proof
I don't hate it see look at that one
block is minus 4 500. that's insane uh I
think it was yeah it was B Thompson who
said Jackson two blocks and then yeah
Jared Jackson two blocks uh smoke mid
420 said Mo went over four I believe
from three last game LOL
um so yeah no no I mean I don't think
we're able to bet mobaba anyway uh yeah
it's Let's uh 25 yeah let's take a look
at the 25 because I definitely see that
also this doesn't really
it doesn't do anything
I would rather I would rather play the
juice or I would rather take the chance
with ad at nearly plus money with two
for two blocks yeah so we don't like uh
chair and Jackson for three blocks no no
minus four and you just got it no no no
we just got a scoop from Mal he said
that uh Jackson blocks are better at
home ah okay Mal wow look at you and Mao
Greg you guys are on the same side how
about that come on now guys are back
genuine men of the people uh bagel and
locks who uh you know I don't want to
say I don't want to say the man of the
people but he's certainly amen of people
after last week he's certainly closer
than you
[Laughter]
I just wanted my should I just walk out
should I even be here he's probably
downstairs you guys can switch [__] he
is downstairs I said hi to him on the
way in here yeah I bet he's waiting
outside the door right now after that
comment you got Wally pimped brother you
got Wally pipped it is what it is
oh man you guys are hilarious but can we
look at Java Ranch points Ryan what do
you like we're just saying we're
ignoring Logan Logan wanted it to go up
to 10 assists do we want to look or we
want to sit at eight look at it I mean
Jackson for two blocks minus 470. while
we were on the page for so long
minus 260. it's
um
this is frustrating I forgot how
frustrating this is what do we want job
points yes please oh definitely get into
it do you want to do this
I've been asking to do that I mean we're
playing verbal tennis here we go from
the early game to the late game the
early game to the late game
it sounds like you don't really like
your job anymore I like your job I love
it it's just he's Greg has so many
demands cameras
over 26 and a half what's 25.
well so he might go for 30 tonight why
do you think this
what did you just say Ryan you just said
that they're well rested they're most
rested that they probably ever been
yeah but well I got I got some numbers I
got some numbers John Moran over 25 and
a half has hit in seven of its last ten
and
I think that he's probably gonna have a
big game I don't know man like
defensively that team doesn't scare me
at all so I'd be fine
I'm good with going 25 and up I this is
my so this is what we have so far we can
talk about it because we're at we're
already at the plus 400 Benchmark right
all we need is plus 400 for it to be
risk-free so we have De'Anthony Melton
one plus three James Harden 10 plus
assists
currently we have John Morant over 26
and a half points and then DeAngelo
Russell over five and a half assists we
have room for one more leg so do we want
to bump jaw down to 25 and then get
something super chalky
as the last flag yes
yeah that's the play Gregory also if we
find something else we like that's not
super chalky we could also bring down
the assists because it's at eight or
it's at ten his line is at 11 and a half
yeah true I dude I I'm I could be talked
into Hardin 14 plus assist tonight I
mean we're talking about somebody who
needed the rest yo
important question here yeah Stephen
Jackson back not I mean Steven Adams I'm
sorry what's going on with me and name
and former NBA players you just name it
Jackson's
I don't know Michael Jackson playing
tonight
Steven Adams isn't back not back
Joe L embiid
yeah I mean like this is this is
becoming a big heavy parlay in the first
game which is totally fine I mean Joel
embiid showed everything off in the
All-Star game he can shoot he can play
Down Low he's gonna grab boards
I my only caution is that Jaron Jackson
is pretty good I don't think he can
guard him like that but that would be my
only hesitation I am not worried about
jiren Jackson in all due respect
with all due respect I feel you Joelle
embiid
so at the moment if we add y'all it has
four legs from the first game and then
we would just need the six assists from
D'Angelo Russell thoughts Ryan
it's a lot of Philly that's a lot of
Philly for you
ah
I'm trying to
I'm trying to be the Vibes guy that I I
promised myself I would be when I woke
up this morning but this is too much in
the first game for me I really liked
bowling before a few weeks ago uh maybe
a month ago or so before almost every
show bowling would come in here and he
would say my goal is just to get to the
second game and I feel like
this is a really risky I agree with you
I'm at the point where I just need to
get to the second game for my own sake
but like I four in the first game is a
lot
where's the risk at my first game though
let's let's go through it like let's
let's actually pull it up go through it
where's the risk where's the real risk
I mean this is going to be my team
because it's my take I would I would
rather
bet eight assists for Harden instead of
10. and if we're gonna add something
else from this game take out the Anthony
Melton because it's a very low leg and
agile and beat in this place
yep
I like that I like that bowling Samantha
prose Pro that's great that's great
thinking
because I know right I mean if if we if
we run into the odd chance that D
Anthony Melton has the ice the Ice Age
game we're gonna all be pissed that we
have in the parlay
um they won't Joel and beat they have a
30 ball tonight 32. oh yeah I saw uh
what was the what was the line from
megalito 11 who said uh
over and beat points with rest he'll be
at his best
um it's a low-grade rhyme
um not a very good one but
I could see I mean
if we want to do Joelle for 30 plus I
don't know what do we think I I mean he
could get 30 in his sleep man that that
we know what's his 25 and what's his 30.
see like it's nice they they fooling
they definitely fool him with your
swapping B kudos to you bro we
definitely gotta lock this in but we're
getting another Scoop from bagel and
locks Logan the legend that helped us
last week in place of urine
um
he um
he basically said uh rumor has it Dylan
Brooks
has never in has never hit an over in
any category
[Laughter]
turned into the Dylan Brooks as a clown
show I am I'm very aligned
I can't stand that person so that's just
my two cents he's flopping and he's fake
tough
um but listen we've run into the same
problem we we would now have four legs
in that first game we gotta find another
winner in game two I think that's just
my take
well I'll ask the audience because I'm
sorry guys I'm disagreeing with y'all
and what in what way
we don't need to force ourselves to to
force ourselves to bet a leg in the
second game if we know we can bet four
winners in the first one but we can we
can take something super low risk in
the second game like you're still
forcing it but you're forcing it bro
am I you
I mean like I
I I think my Wi-Fi is broken
call the technician
I don't hate I don't listen
I don't hate what Ryan just did I don't
hate it what did he do Anthony Davis
Anthony Davis 20 plus points and we're
at Plus 469. okay okay Ryan you might be
whipping up some what's the locks though
let's let's go over it let's go over it
let's talk it through it so we've got
John Morant 25 plus points James Harden
eight plus assists that may cash in the
first quarter Joella bead 30 plus
DeAngelo Russell over five and a half
assists and Anthony Davis 20 plus points
I like this only one I'm like and I
don't even think I'm really like yeah is
that D'Angelo Russell but but I like it
though I like it let me let me take a
quick look at his numbers I I'm pretty
sure this D'Angelo Russell leg is pretty
lucky
um when he was with the T wolves he was
getting this number a lot the only thing
is he's obviously on a new old team but
there's a lot of opportunity I mean like
he's going to be feeding in the pick and
roll with Anthony Davis LeBron is LeBron
they've got better shooting now Ryan I
see what you did there yeah yeah 80 80
points I see I see what you did bro
I see what you did what about five
minutes yeah I think I think the five is
the play
I tried five and a half I'm not too
worried about it guys can we go five
plus what is what does five plus look
like yeah we can't it goes It goes by
two all right no that's what I'm trying
I was trying to do over four and a half
just take it down a bit but there we
would need to slowly increase something
James Harden 10. you said he can get it
or or we could get over James Harden 10
or over eight and a half
here we go here we go this is gonna be
huge it's gonna be huge if we could do
this the old Dougie brother whoa wait I
gotta confirm something really quick
also
oh God okay
shout out to Keys need one
D'Angelo Russell's birthday today I love
a birthday narrative we love a birthday
narrative so he's gonna go he's gonna
have a triple double
he might
he might strip dubs I'm not a big Ohio
State guy fan but I love me a good
narrative
trip dubsky guys were so close to plus
400 we don't need to get there Ryan we
can just lock it in here it's not
risk-free if it's not plus 400. oh okay
yeah I forgot about that wait wait so
where were we at before we we needed
five and a half assists from Russell I'm
I'm pretty confident in that I'm not
even gonna lie I bumped it down to four
and a half I
I don't know in his three games and his
three games with the Lakers he's got
seven four and six
who won he didn't have the one he didn't
have he played only 28 minutes
so yo why can't uh FanDuel work its
magic and get us over plus 400 you know
like just moved along
right it's literally just a nudge it's
like we're right at the one yard line
move the line a little
ah
I think we stick with the OG let's ask
let's read the OG out and and ask the uh
and ask the audience because I think we
all liked it I think we all were aligned
on now we was fooling with it I ain't
gonna lie are we okay what if we but
what if we did the 10 plus for Hardin or
we we just want to go back to completely
just over five and a half for D'Angelo
Russell and eight eight for Hardin I
like okay so now we're getting smoke gas
420 saying Delo two threes
Dilo 3 is better but okay Jay Clark
saying Delo threes
are they Delo he will pop them threes I
ain't gonna lie but he'll dish
it too all right he's hit at least two
in one two three four five foot seven
eight nine no no no you're going too far
back Brolin just go with the Lakers
games because you know he had a
different role
he's hit it in two of his last three
he had three in the last game against
the Pelicans two against the Blazers and
then one of three against the Warriors
and that was his first game
or what we can do this is a bowling how
many how many assists did he have in
that Warriors game
he had six assists in the Warriors game
I think we take the assist they're
playing The Warriors tonight
I think we take the assist too I have a
I have an idea I'm a genius I'm I'm so
smart
boom
for those of you who didn't see what I
just did there for those of you who
didn't who didn't see what I just did
there was a matter of what four and a
half no it's it's gonna do that I think
it's gonna do the same thing but hold on
okay wow now lock it in now lock it in
now
okay lock it in lock it in take a
picture this this I feel good about this
so yeah screenshot okay all right all
right here we go it is Joe lmbed 30 plus
points James Harden over eight and a
half assists it will cash in the first
three minutes John Moran over 24 and a
half points then in the late game scroll
hold on hold on Anthony Davis 20 plus
points D'Angelo Russell on his birthday
according to Michael bowling if that's
not true remember Michael Boling said it
uh 223 1996 according to Google Just yes
uh
plus 401 uh
screenshot
screenshot plus screenshot there it is
and we need cameras in the comments
cameras in the comments because we're
screenshotting it camera I feel good
about this one guys I'm fired up about
this one this is I think this is our
best
dude I don't I don't usually love a
parlay like that that I love this parlay
I love this part that's what I'm talking
about bro you need to bring that energy
more and maybe we might win more we just
you know what it is we finagled it we we
worked it around finesse finesse finesse
Finance
it's my New York slang oh
it went down no we screenshot it though
we we screenshot it
bro that's so crazy like what
how is that possible
that's we got the camera in the chat too
bro this is sickening bro they all
screenshotted it
oh no wait hey Ryan just go up to 25 and
a half and we're good just go up 25 and
a half we're good with y'all you already
know I want this documented right now
I already know Josh is gonna score 25
points tonight
no Vibes are gone Vibes are gone Rat's
Nest tear it down it's over it's done I
think what I think what we need to do
is just wait a little bit we'll finish
the show there's no reason to be alarmed
this will get back to 400. I'm sure of
it wait if we get back to uh if I go
back to 25 plus it's not going to do
anything
God
all right thanks so much
we're good we're good wait go back go
back go back Ryan go back to uh 24 and a
half I just want to see if it went up if
it changed no I didn't my bad all good
it's all good all right so the
disclaimer is everyone who's in here
knows the real play if you want to just
wait and see if you want to wait and see
if it moves we will accept the tickets
for both parlays because that was
Madness
Traders are listening and watching the
show so shout out to y'all because they
moved the line on us The Vibes were way
too high yeah that was crazy I'm not
gonna lie that was the best I think I
had ever felt about a parlay I'll be
honest with you
and it's a matter of one point that is
completely changed my mind
it's okay I think we'll be I think we'll
be good are we locking this one in wait
we have no choice unfortunately all
right if you guys want to tell our five
leg parlay make sure you guys head on
over to FanDuel and opt into the TNT
Thursdays no sweat parlay for free bet
if it loses uh
how you guys feeling about NBA today I'm
I'm happy that it's back
so happy it's back I mean it was
basically like shooting shooting darts
into the abyss trying to figure out what
to bet without the NBA so glad we have
something to bet on
I'm not gonna get over I'm not gonna get
over that guys
hey Ryan
's brother
what's the point it's John he's gonna I
think he's going for 30 tonight to be
honest I I want everyone to know if this
does happen where he scores 25 points
and every other leg hits you don't have
to we have it documented one and you
don't have to ask yourself the question
I will cry I will all right that'll
happen wait I got an update from the
chat shout out to highest odds he says
please read you will bump odds if you
grab job 25 plus instead of 24 and a
half please read
no read my comment to get the odds up is
that possible all right okay what is His
Highest odds what hold on highest odds
acted like Greg yelling at me to go back
to 25 plus I just did this but I'll do
it again
no he did just do it I did like we're
wasting time now to be honest plus 394.
we're stuck we just did this right I
know all right
wait just try
screenshot screenshot everyone go go bet
it go back again read it okay all right
okay it's I'll read it out as I do it
it's Joel embiid 30 plus James Harden
over eight
and a half assists John Morant 25 plus
points Anthony Davis 20 plus points
D'Angelo Russell over four and a half
assists
screenshot screenshot
one more time
screenshot
screenshot I gotta I gotta bet this MVR
look at Mark Van reef everybody look at
Mark Van Reef comment he just commented
duplicated
meet cameras in the comments a lot of
cameras in the comments because we're
making a point here we're screenshotting
this it's plus 403 Ryan's feeling good
I'm feeling good and B's feeling good
Ryan's trying to go Ryan's trying to go
get this right now
ah
it moved again
tell me it didn't oh my God yo like
awesome all right we gotta wait then we
just gotta wait that's all it is awesome
awesome real like
yeah
I feel like we're being played with
right now yeah like what's going on like
for real for real like hold on like
what's going on oh my God my emotions
are damaged right we got to go back to
the 25 plus and we'll just again
everyone who was here remember
if you want to wait remember what we
originally said but this is what we have
to do right
so this is what we have to do right now
sorry try to play right I saw it bro I
was like minus 180 like three minutes
ago yeah bro and that was why this was
72.
okay all right
again remember if you'd like to wait
until 7 30 Eastern time you remember the
real one but this is what we have to do
which is John Morant over 25 and a half
points James Harden over eight and a
half assists D'Angelo Russell over four
and a half assists and B 30 plus points
Anthony Davis 20 plus points five legs
plus 430 risk-free over at FanDuel go
bet it
were you able to get it in the original
uh no I was I I uh you had a lot going
on I tried I was really close too so
I'll monitor it
I was on leg four when I was when I was
going through here
it looks like man that's so tough anyway
but we can we can move on yeah that that
that's tough let's let's grade a couple
bets uh
flipped out what says 10 points for
Melton plus 125 is a lot you guys
bagel and locks we need you here
you like that Ryan he said listen he
said Revenge game so I I and you know
Logan knows all so I'm gonna I'm gonna
take Logan's uh take Logan's advice
apply here for the grade I'm gonna give
it an a oh wow peep this one peep this
one
Blaze says leave everything the same and
add Brawn to get 20 points your answer
is no
we're not adding a leg I don't want to
add a leg
I got another I got another candidate
because we need a squad ride what do you
guys think outside of TNT games Jalen
Williams rookie over 20 and a half
points rebounds and assists minus 115
against the Utah Jazz who should well
probably won't be hungover well yeah no
it's impossible for them to be hungover
uh they only had one R Star right
yeah also you know alcohol in Utah is
not really a thing but yeah true true
talk for another time but uh
20 at pra 20 and a half that's kind of
low I I yeah in Utah
in Utah yeah I'll take it
mb12 rebound I think so
and b12 rebounds I think so I would take
that Squad ride I would take this even
Adams yeah what's there what's the
original number at it's at I think it's
11 and a half yeah not mistake yeah that
should be the squad Ride ziby three two
six yeah three two six it sounds like we
have a winner Logan I see you in the
chat let's fire up this squad ride 12
boards Blaze one Blaze one said Brom 20
20 plus is safer than any picture I have
I agree
I agree but I think that our parlay is
still lucky like there's no bad vibes
thrown at my parlay you know what I'm
saying I think we're good to go yeah
let's I don't want to hear that that's
not what I want to hear right now yeah I
don't I mean you know he we being the
man of the people Ryan it's my name
right being a man of the people though
you have to accept
you know their comments you have to
accept their criticism when if you are a
true man of the people you have to
listen to them because people like to be
listened to you know what I'm saying
because you know what I've been doing
while you guys have been arguing I've
been holding this up in case it moves so
that I could just lock it in right away
yeah I want the original far late so bad
so do I oh my God all right although I'm
not the punt to 25 and a half is not
unreasonable I mean I think John's gonna
have a big night I think Joel's gonna
have a big night
but
you know we're always safeguarding
against Ryan's worst fear thank you all
right thank you guys I'm here the
producers in my ear we got to get up out
of here we we haven't seen each other
been around each other did a show in so
long so we're like growing out right now
way over I know we're like growing out I
haven't seen like I daring 85 in Forever
how am I supposed to leave them like
that
hey Ryan read the parlay one more time
quickly and then we're gonna get up out
of here this guy in the reading the
parlay dude Joe I didn't miss that I'll
tell you that much Joe lnb 30 plus
points James Harden over eight and a
half assists John Moran over 25 and a
half points Anthony Davis 20 plus points
and D'Angelo Russell over four and a
half assists plus plus 430 make sure you
guys screenshot I hope you guys been
screenshotting all day like we've been
telling you guys too uh let's Get on Up
out of here man it's a lot of money to
be made NBA is back
Juiced about that I don't know about
Charles a lot of money to people my name
is Greg Ivory next to me is the man of
the app I call him MB you can call him
MB but his name is Michael Bowen and
next to him is the man we like to call
producer Ryan here on this show we
we out of this thing y'all peace
[Music]
oh